only yes it is Yes sex without consent
is rape and sexually exploiting
a woman is not only selling her body it
is also forcing her to have sex without her
consent once again we commemorate
in the European Parliament the
international day to combat violence
against women  I wish we didn't have to
do it, we have taken an important
step forward, the European Union has
finally ratified the
Istanbul Convention, but we continue to move forward, we have to
continue moving forward, right now we have
a proposal for a directive on the table
to fight against violence against
women. Let's not lose this  opportunity
to have a useful directive to
defend and protect all women
who suffer gender violence and I want to
recover our demand that
gender violence be added to the
list of crimes included in the treaty
that already contemplates trafficking in
human beings  and the sexual exploitation of
women and children, only then can we have
a common definition of
gender violence that includes all cases
of violence applicable uniformly
throughout the European Union and that allows the
aggressors to be prosecuted and
victims to be protected in all areas.  countries of the
European Union and crimes do not go
unpunished